hello everyone
i'm in miami today on my tour it's the
end of january
i've been watching what's happening in
canada
over the last 10 days let's say or
months before that too
wondering what's going on and trying to
think it through
i thought i'd
make a video today
a message to
premier scott mill and jason kenney and
doug ford and
leader of her majesty's loyal opposition
aaron o'toole and ask you guys what in
the world are you waiting for
it's your moment
you've got a huge number of canadians
occupying ottawa
expressing their dismay with the
suspension of our charter rights in the
face of this so-called emergency
our prime minister has
literally abandoned the city run away as
far as i can tell
citing security concerns because i think
he believes his own propaganda about the
nature of the people who are sitting in
ottawa and then lying about it
justifying it as a consequence of being
exposed to kovid despite the fact he's
double vaccinated and tested negative
you're not going to get a better
opportunity this is your moment
conservatives in canada
you could come out and say to the
population say to the people who are
desperate to hear this that
we can have our lives returned to normal
and that there's still some danger but
that we've got this with competent
leadership and care
we could return our lives to what they
should be
we could have our country back we could
move forward into the future in a normal
manner
so gentlemen premier scott moe jason
kenny
doug ford you're good man aaron o'toole
you're the leader of the opposition
man even the ndp leader came out and
said that the
truckers were
essentially a bunch of white
supremacists for
for all intents and purposes
the opposition your opposition our
government is in disarray
and the people are doing everything they
can to
make their wants known guys
reassure canadians
remove these
mandates that are crippling our
businesses and interfering with our
private lives and stopping us from being
able to travel
seize the day